scusa tu chi sei io ti ho fatto un
inventario
[Musica]
mi fate fare
e ora che cosa facciamo non possiamo
rimanere rinchiusi qua no che non
possiamo e non abbiamo neanche cibo che
urlino aiutaci tu che cosa stai pensando
pure tu stai pensando a mangiare vero e
giusto c a trovare la chiave per uscire
dai merlina sta guardando fuori dalla
finestra forse vuole dire che c'è una
chiave o fuori no non c'è niente
forse vuole dire che dobbiamo scappare
dalla finestra
non lo ferma cui si può scappare dalla
finestra è troppo pericoloso puramente
dobbiamo trovare un'altra soluzione però
è una berlina vuole solo dormire oppure
vuole essere scambiato come un po peggio
visto che si è messo sul tavolo degli
scambi
forse cio c'e può aiutarci puoi aiutarci
a trovare la chiave un modo per scappare
da qua morin chiusi qua dentro
non possiamo scappare dalla finestra
forse ci dice sì condurrà della chiave
vediamo
dai certo circe cerca
sotto al letto
dimmi e quella chiave
è andata sotto il letto c'è chi cosa hai
trovato sotto il letto
cosa c'è la prova guarda
una chiave una chiave cantici leggete e
bravissima la mia prima lo avresti
dovuto trovare tu col tuo fiuto luigi di
stare liszt bivaccato presto proviamo la
subito vediamo se si può uscire forse la
chiave giusta
sempre
grazie
a un'idea persi due a controllare al
piano di sotto io controllo qua al piano
di sopra perché le bambole cattive
potrebbero ancora essere davvero ottima
idea vado subito fermati così da
mangiare ma mica stavo pensando a
mangiare e uno attragga e
speriamo che è vitale non si ferma in
cucina a mangiare devo iniziare a
controllare tutte le stanze per vedere
dove sono le bambole berlino tu hai
visto qualcosa
qualcuno
va bene ho capito che vuoi dormire o
merlino come sempre
un buon muro
come hai fatto ad entrare cuore
no forse è meglio non toccarla
un'idea
di
becca di questo vai di enac radar o
trochei
perché non si sia arrabbiata
system e gli utenti avvicini ok
sembra una bambola normalissima forse io
e vitale ci siamo immaginati tutto ciò
che ne pensi circe guardando una bambina
normale
guarda il sir c'e
anche le ciglia qui a una collana perché
vuoi attaccarla circe che ti ha fatto di
male non so come abbiamo fatto io e
vitale a spaventarci una normalissima
bambola di plastica
anzi è anche carina
magari l'appoggio vicino berlino vediamo
cosa ne penso a merlino e mi arriva che
ne pensi di questa bambola ti piace
berlino non reagisce il che vuol dire
che non è una bambola pericolosa vero
altrimenti avrebbe provato a mangiarla
come ogni altra cosa
fate gli occhi bellissimi
[Musica]
in italia sono stato in cucina e non
certo c'è niente a parte degli snack che
ho prontamente sgranocchiato
base è quella la mia bambola
pettinando non è bellissima come la tua
bambola bellaria una bambola cattiva e
una di quelle che c'è il rinchiuso qua
dentro rinchiuso qua dentro ma che di
certo non siamo richiusi qua dentro c'è
la porta aperta corte che bei capelli
biondi che ne sarebbero pieni boccoli
secondo te i boccoli
ma i broccoli semmai abbiamo quelli si
possono mangiare tenti il loro tempo per
la tua negatività adesso lei deve stare
tranquilla e serena altrimenti e se
rovineranno i capelli quindi lasciami in
pace con la mia bambola e fare pure via
ciao ciao stai dicendo è solo una
bambola guarda la vedi a bola malato
classico perché non devo toccare solo
una bambola cazzola no
come hai usato
farle del male ma sei impazzita con
questa bambola da me la
media
allora ma che fatica
ma mi ha morso
per fortuna stai bene
non ti preoccupare ora se ne andrà via
ma è impazzito a vita
il co fatto
ora sei di nuovo bettini attacco per
prima devo trovare una soluzione
e giunto il momento
di fare dei cambiamenti
così faremo ancora più unite
vero
[Musica]
manca qualcosa
manca ancora
chi è quella ragazza
marino hai visto entrare è meglio se il
mio nuovo piano piano e scopro che è
scusi chi è chi è lei
ma scusa tu chi sei
io non ti ho fatto entrare qua ti ha
fatto entrare qualcuno glielo tuffatori
che entrare
[Musica]
chi mi ha fatto entrare
i beni
sparita che cosa ti è successo che
cos'ha fatto ai capelli io
domani cosa hai fatto ai capelli
[Musica]
sì cioè no no nel senso cioè sim 6
differente tutti stanno bene
sto dicendo che stai male ma dire che
queste va bene si ok ok ma perché è
deciso di farti bionda e sentirsi non vi
dico quale i romani
ora siamo ancora più vicini perché
sistemi gli utenti di poteri
sei impazzita del tutto ne sono sicuro
no ti fa male questa bambola ti sta
cambiando totalmente
ridammi
seguito
ti fa male
allontanati o non butta a terra la butta
a terra una novità la butta lì da me è
subito altrimenti
complimenti
[Musica]
finché non torni ad essere normale cioè
la vita di sempre
io non ti darò la bambola
l'accordo non mi
va bene
e va bene è una bambola
sapevo che avrebbe funzionato
ed i piatti che
male c testate in piedi
ciao ragazzi e sono scappato qui in
giardino per non essere preso da anita
la bambola bionda dobbiamo trovare una
soluzione per far tornare all'inter
normale lasciate un mi piace in modo da
aiutarmi ho notato che unito sia
arrabbiata quando l'ho tolta la bambola
quindi forse la bambola che la tiene in
questa sorta di ipnosi
quindi forse ho capito cosa devo fare le
devo togliere la bambola così l'ipnosi
si interromperà e potrà tornare normale
come faccio a togliergli al avevo
elaborare un piano
ma
andiamo
[Musica]
anita
la vita di
chi guarda un po
guarda che cosa ho qui
il perché
ecco dov'era deve averlo rubato
mentre fuggita come fai adesso a
pettinare i capelli della bambola mai
capito i tuoi e qui viene a prenderla
terra assolutamente andare a prenderla e
l'unica spazzola che fa bene per i
bellissimi capelli per la mia patria
beh ti consiglio di sbrigarti e veniva a
prenderla altrimenti perché il rum
berlino e si sporcherà e non la potrei
più utilizzate
dovrete dammi subito il pet e
giovedì 6 nascosto
ei
cani dove
era proprio quel giardino
devo prenderla prima che arrivi
dovesse fare il nascosta
e gli sanità ciao fabbricato spazzola e
anche la sua bambola
e adesso più ne occuperò io di lei ciao
oh cavolo sia una pianta tantissimo
bisogna scappare
[Musica]
dove sei
dove sei finito dov'è la mia pub la
parola tavola con me a vita dovrebbe
tornare al normale
o almeno è quello che spero
[Musica]